you know
trace mcsorley quite honestly really
stood out to me
because
imagine your season is on the line
and all you can do is to come in and
try to figure out anything to get this
team going you're you're you're down
35-34
and you've got to do anything possible
you know the marquis brown drop
was huge for them right you may not have
even needed this drama at the end if
marquise brown
you know uh doing his best deonte
johnson doesn't drop that ball but to me
what really fascinated me is what was
going on on the sidelines
you know when
uh trace mcsorley is laying there and
when he's laying there you've got willie
snead who is going up and down the ball
up and down the sidelines saying give me
a ball give me a ball because he's got
to take some snaps
he's the emergency quarterback and he
figures he's going in there
and so i mean there was it was organized
chaos you've got you've got justin
tucker saying to harvest i i might have
to go in and hit this to to john
harbaugh and then you've got willie
snead quickly taking some snaps and then
out of the tunnel somebody says hey
lamar's coming and lamar jackson is
coming out of the tunnel and just kind
of the chaos of it all and the fun of it
all because you know what mike lamar
jackson was not coming out of the locker
room if if if mcsorley is not laying
there on the ground
chris i was waiting for you to respond
it was so smooth until you didn't
respond well i didn't know i mean you
asked him if i didn't know
that i should
it's been a while since we've done the
three-man weave that's kind of how it
goes he talks you respond i pick it up
we go from there but it's been a while
we all get a little bit of a break here
but peter that monday night game i i i i
think that moment when you see lamar
jackson coming out of the locker room
and back onto the field and then what he
does with it the fact that he throws it
because i would have sworn this guy's
gonna run the ball it's just five yards
he can get five yards rolling out of bed
and extend the drive to throw it and
then to throw it to of all people
mr dropsy on the baltimore ravens
marquis brown and he catches it and he
scores a touchdown that took what was
a a pretty damn good monday night game
yeah and just thrusted into the pantheon
chris what do you think well okay sorry
i didn't know you just asked him i
thought maybe you'd come back with
another question so
i i mean first off off of what peter
said all right first i i kind of said
this yesterday i mean if mcsorley just
kind of limps himself off the sideline
in a hurry
the moment never happens right that's to
me the amazing thing like til peter said
the fact that he laid there and did that
that gave lamar jackson the time to run
out of the locker room and get in there
for the fourth time that's amazing
here's one little football aspect that i
just think is amazing about that play
itself fourth down you know this is
where like division rivals know each
other the the cleveland browns bringing
all out blitz they they're bringing
they're bringing the house basically
it's there's no safety in the middle of
the field it's just four one on ones
across the field but the ravens must
have had a good feel for that blitz to
be coming and they figured out how to
pick it up and also get their back out
into the flat right you saw jk dobbins
there he was one of those guys where
you're like just throw it to him it's
gonna be a first down but within that
okay olivier vernon who they're
expecting hey you'll be able to blitz
because jk dobbins is gonna have to pick
up some other blitz right he's gonna so
you'll be able to go too he has to run
and cover jk dobbins they get the back
out of the backfield what is that what
happens olivier vernon runs into the guy
that's covering hollywood brown
and i just found that to be a very
interesting x and 0 development there of
a team that kind of had like a feel for
this is what you're going to do
and
and then of course made the play and it
kind of backfired on the browns and
everything like that to have a defensive
end in the flat covering a running back
and you saw what happened
okay
mike if i can if i can if i can just
intercede one thing about
to me what was
let's let's lay this layer on top of it
okay and that is
the only thing that's at stake here is
baltimore's season yeah you know that's
if they lose this game there's a very
good chance they're not making the
playoffs
okay so if they lose this game just
think about it you know they go to seven
and six
and they've got even if they
you know win them all down the stretch
which they very well well may do even if
they win them all ten and six guarantees
nothing and
it's like what justin tucker said
every game for us right now everyone is
a playoff game
and and again listen i i understand that
that lamar jackson probably was because
somebody who saw him in the locker room
you know during his exile in there said
that he was up on his tiptoes trying to
hasten
the uh
you know the cramps to get out of there
and and and they they had already pumped
so much
solution into them that they were trying
to hurry it up and and look who knows
what would happen
on fourth and five if trace mcsorley
just pops up
and he gets up there and you're gonna go
for it either that or or how about this
you know
62-yard field goal try remember what you
just saw justin tucker saying hey i
might have to hit this
now i i don't know if you're john
harbaugh
do you trust trace mcsorley to convert
fourth and five
more than you trust your kicker
to make a 62-yard field goal
with an 18 mile an hour crosswind
and that to me is a great question
because look
we all saw the 55-yard field goal go
right through
but if you watch that field goal closely
and chris if you go on to
nfl game pass and you look at the
coaches tape
i want you to look at the action of that
kick
late in the kick and you know what
you're gonna see
it starts off here right hand side right
and goes over here right at the end so
who's to say
that a 62-yard field goal even if he has
it
even he had plenty of foot yeah on the
55-yard field goal but if it's a 62-yard
field goal it could have gone wide so
it's just uh i mean this is one of these
things
that quite honestly you could do a
two-hour show on and discuss all of
these little things and what could have
happened but that's what made that such
a fascinating thing mike and the fact
that the ravens now have that mentality
where their backs are against the wall
and they have to win every week every
week is a playoff game in a weird sort
of way
that may help them
win
a playoff game that was the narrative
going into the season hey they're gonna
have another great regular season
can they win in january lamar jackson
can't win a playoff game it was becoming
a a barry bonds type narrative that when
they get to the games that matter lamar
can't get it done when you're churning
through these games chris in december
that you have to win you have to win you
have to win by the time you get to the
playoffs
it's just another week there's no
mystique about it because you've been in
this mode for a month now yeah you're in
the desperation mode there's there's
nothing you know there's there's it's no
other there's no other way you can play
or survive so you've found a way to like
you know have your intensity and level
of focus and and and play off you know
shape here through a number of weeks to
where it gets to the playoffs and maybe
one team is like whoa wait things are a
little different this week and getting
adjusted and the other team rolls into
town is like oh big playoffs so what you
know there's a few more media guys here
we've been in the playoffs for six weeks
you know we saw it last year i mean the
tennessee titans that's that's what
happened with them right i mean it's the
same kind of same kind of thing you know
yeah they were a 9-7 football team they
had to be in playoff mode throughout
december and that allowed them to oh
catch the baltimore ravens who have
taken a few weeks off and we've been in
bar room brawls you know at the end of
the regular season and won a playoff
game and a bar room brawl against the
patriots and now here's the ravens like
well we got to get used to things again
and bam bam bam you're smacked in the
mouth and all of a sudden you're losing
the divisional playoff game you're
supposed to be winning
the other x factor in here chris
obviously is that you know the ravens
know what their past has been their very
recent past you know they had home field
advantage over the chargers in
2018 and they spit the bit and
particularly lamar jackson in that game
then last season they spit the bit again
and uh
lamar jackson doesn't play well again
in a huge playoff game this time when
they're the number one seed uh to
tennessee so
they understand that you know the the
historical clock is ticking
and it's against them right now so
every one of the games that they play
like they played on monday night in my
opinion
is a booster shot
for lamar jackson
in his uh i think um and i'm not saying
that mentally it weighs on him what do i
know i'm not in his body i don't know
but from the outside lamar jackson's got
to know that hey listen his record in
big games at the end of the at a lot of
these games not the greatest
so
that is obviously a check mark on the
plus side for him
and you know to get back to something
that chris and i were discussing last
hour and i was resisting just because i
felt like resisting chris the idea that
the bills
or the steelers for that matter
parked at the number two seat
contemplating what to do week 17 knowing
that there's a damn good chance the
ravens are the team coming to town in
the wild card round chris i have to
admit i'm softening my stance on this
maybe there is value in being the three
seed instead of the number two seed if
the ravens continue this head of steam
because i don't think the steelers want
him again with a full complement of
players including lamar jackson and i
don't think the bills want to mess with
him either chris i mean it would be the
last team i'd want to see coming to town
you know
you know for lack of a better phrase
pissed off baltimore ravens team that's
been in playoff mode and bully mode for
the last five weeks
you know and then deal with that running
game and lamar jackson and everything he
can do and then you know again
the other thing we're forgetting here
the ravens defense is not healthy it's
just kind of starting to get some guys
back to where they've been very average
i mean they haven't even been good the
last five weeks on defense not average
they have not been good i mean baker
mayfield and company moved the ball and
will at will on them i mean uh so i i
mean you're right mike i mean that that
to me is going to be part of this and
how mcdermott or whoever is mike tomlin
in that situation the psychology of it
you know the message you want to send to
your team and then okay the reality of
actually who we want to play that wild
card round uh i think it's something
that's certainly going to be worth
debating when you get to that time
whoever that is the bills are the
steelers
you know the other part is you know
obviously
if you're the three seed you're gonna
get one home game and that's probably it
in the playoffs
and look i don't think home field means
very much this year
but it means something
and
you know the pittsburgh steelers i think
would at least consider
do we want to go to buffalo again
i mean do we want to set it up right so
that in the in the divisional round you
know on uh uh
january 16th or 17th
do we want to set it up so that we're
going back to orchard park and again no
fans but still there's something about
being on the road in that game that is
not good i think
at that at that time of the playoffs and
look there's no guarantee that the
ravens are going to be the seventh seed
they're just you know it's
it's such a weird year
because look if the ravens are 11 and
five
i think they're going to be better than
the seventh seed and we'll see what
happens but
i think if you look at
the the the way this is going to fall it
looks like right now that
buffalo and pittsburgh
could well be fighting
for that uh you know for that two seed
and if they are there are a lot more
factors at stake than just who gets the
home game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports